So, now you've seen graphical depictions of functions. We've talked about real
world examples of functions. And I think it's finally time to talk about what a
function really is mathematically. So, overall what does a function do? Well, it
takes some value as it's input, does some stuff to that value, and then produces
a new number called the output. Then we can pair that input value with the
output value that it produces to graph our functions. So, over here we have our
x's and over here we have our y's, in general. So, for example, let's say I have
a function whose function is to increase the input value by 2. So, for example,
if our input is 2, so if you take 2 and throw it into our function machine, then
the function machine will spit out an output of 4. So instead of 2, our input is
5. What will the output be from the same function?